Usually what you see in a movie was put there
on purpose—but not always. We've already
covered strange things accidentally included
in the background of movies, such as the unzipped
extra in Teen Wolf, the head-bonking Stormtrooper
in Star Wars, and a parked car in Braveheart
- all of which and more you can find in our
video, 20 Movie Mistakes You Never Noticed.
But here are five more background bloopers
you can still catch on-screen...
Think fast
There's an amazing moment in Being John Malkovich:
"Hey Malkovich, think fast!"
"Ah!"
While the scene calling for Malkovich to get
hit with the can seems to have been planned,
the "think fast" line apparently wasn't. Director
Spike Jonze said in an audio commentary that
a bunch of extras working on the film snuck
a case of beer on set, and were getting "pretty
lit." The director added that the line the
can-thrower yelled as the car zoomed past
earned him his Screen Actors Guild card, bumping
his pay from $100 a day to $700. Not a bad
way to earn a raise.
Hazard pay
During a key scene in The Last Samurai, Tom
Cruise's character arrives on horseback for
the film's epic final battle. As Cruise dismounts
from his horse, the animal can actually be
seen kicking one of the extras in the groin.
Instead of dropping to the ground and crying,
the extra simply takes a step back, reacts
silently, and regroups in formation. Samurai
are known for being disciplined. This guy
went the extra mile.
A random cowboy
Nobody watching Pirates of the Caribbean:
The Curse of the Black Pearl could've expected
what went down in its final scene. After reclaiming
the Black Pearl, Captain Jack Sparrow orders
his merry band of pirates to get to work on
the deck. Just as they begin to move, a man
wearing a white t-shirt and a cowboy hat can
be spotted in the background, looking off
into distant waters. Was this mysterious man's
cameo a secret Easter Egg, or perhaps a character
to be introduced in the sequels?
No, he was supposedly just a grip crew member
who forgot to clear the set during filming.
Fraidy cat
Classic Bond villain Blofeld's white Persian
cat is a pretty creepy customer in You Only
Live Twice. The furry creature loses a bit
of luster when it legitimately freaks out
during one of the explosion scenes towards
the end of the film. Donald Pleasence, who
plays Blofeld, does his best to keep the cat
clutched tightly to his body; but for a few
brief moments, the camera captures the frantic
feline scrambling for the nearest possible
exit. It's safe to say the cat was both shaken
and stirred.
Dog Days
Remember the early '90s when pro-wrestler
Hulk Hogan attempted a movie career? It didn't
work. In fact, the only reason anyone talks
about his 1993 feature, Mister Nanny, has
nothing to do with the Hulkster. While Hogan
tools around on his motorcycle, the camera
captures one of the most bizarre sights in
cinema.
Your eyes aren't playing tricks on you. Some
random dude threw a dog into the ocean.
Why? Who is he? Did the dog stink or something?
Was the motorcycle-riding montage so important
that this footage needed to stay in the final
cut?
The only other question is what makes Hulk
Hogan prouder: riding his motorcycle in front
of a dog being thrown in the ocean, or that
time he opened a pasta restaurant in the Mall
of America for some reason:
"Pastamania has got all my Hulkamaniacs running
wild. And I've eaten so many Hulkaroos and
Hulkayoos, I kinda feel sorry for Big Bubba
brother!"
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which crazy background moments we
missed...